La ola de violencia en Haití trajo un
repunte en los asesinatos de policías en
tan solo tres semanas las bandas
criminales mataron a dieciocho
uniformados seis de ellos El miércoles
de la semana pasada al día siguiente
cientos de policías Se tomaron las
calles para protestar y obstruyeron el
aeropuerto de tuzant en Puerto Príncipe
donde se esperaba que el Primer Ministro
Ariel aterrizara luego de ir a Argentina
para participar en la celac los
manifestantes dispararon al aire y
dañaron parte de la residencia del
Premier para hablar de este tema nos
conectamos con nuestro segundo invitado
del día él es Joseph Harold economista y
politólogo portador de la idea de una
nueva opinión pública en Haití
Bienvenido a France 24 un poco para
poner en contexto lo que está ocurriendo
y estas protestas explíquenos qué tanto
poder tienen las bandas criminales en
Haití especialmente en la capital
muy buenos días María Clara
Haití las bandas criminales tienen de
las bandas criminales tienen más poder
que el mismo gobierno porque las bandas
criminales controlan todo el territorio
evidentemente tienen más poder en Puerto
Príncipe están mejor dicho más
desplegados en despegadas en Puerto
principe y también en otro departamento
otra provincia que se llama el arte
bonito pero tienen la capacidad de
controlar todo el país O sea cualquier
discurso del Primer Ministro del
gobierno no es más que un discurso pero
no tienen porque no tienen la capacidad
de contrarrestar El poder de las bandas
en el país bueno Y más allá de este
poder de las bandas lo que ha dicho la
policía Es que la violencia ha aumentado
desde que agilen asumió como Primer
Ministro el 5 de julio de 2021 y de
hecho hay una cifra de la red Nacional
de defensa por los Derechos Humanos que
dice que desde que el rey asumió el
cargo 78
días han sido asesinados realmente hay
una inacción del parte del gobierno o
qué está haciendo el Primer Ministro
Bueno
si hago una inacción Pero yo no creo que
el gobierno primero es cierto que la
violencia se ha intensificado en el país
hay una inacción del gobierno pero no
creo que lo tenga capacidad que actuar
en el texto No creo que tenga la
capacidad tampoco el pasado
desgraciadamente asesinado tampoco este
gobierno tenía la capacidad de
contrarrestar El Poder el poder las
bandas porque eso primero porque la
policía no tiene la capacidad no tiene
el entrenamiento no tiene las municiones
es más La policía haitiana tiene 13.000
miembros para 12 millones de habitantes
eso hace un policía que habitantes
mientras el promedio del mundo es como
400 policías como cuatro policías por
mil habitantes
Y es más en América Latina países como
El Salvador que tiene digamos
situaciones difíciles tienen 27,000
policías y 40
48.000 soldados Eso significa 75.000
miembros por seis millones de habitantes
eso hace 12 uniformados por mil
habitantes lo que significa que en Haití
hay un vacío total de fuerza en el país
fuerza digamos oficial y la razón
principal de eso es la inexistencia
total del estado haitiano porque son los
políticos que han contribuido son los
políticos que han llevado al país a este
nivel Porque la única responsabilidad o
el único objetivo del del Estado
haitiano es bueno primero es un estado
creptocrático su única responsabilidad
es robar o sea para mí no hay una
diferencia abismal no hay una gran
diferencia entre
al estado o el gobierno y las bandas la
única diferencia es que el estado no
está involucrado en digamos
secuestros como la policía como perdón
como las bandas pero en término de
irresponsabilidad es exactamente lo
mismo y es más hay que saberlo el estado
siempre ha estado vinculado con las
bandas y hay bandas que están por
supuesto bajo la acción del Estado ahora
mismo Hay muchas que son digamos bandas
autónomas pero al inicio las bandas
fueron formadas por
políticos para ganar elecciones y para
hacer disolubles en el país es decir que
es el resultado de la inexistencia total
del estado haitiano y como usted lo
señalaba hay un vacío frente a la
cantidad de policías y militares
respecto a la población en Haití y
precisamente por eso el Primer Ministro
de Ariel el año pasado le pidió a que
envíe fuerzas especiales internacionales
a pesar de que hubo una misión de paz de
la ONU entre 2004 y 2017 que fue muy
criticada porque varios de sus miembros
fueron señalados de violar mujeres de
estar involucrados en la explotación
infantil entre otros hechos a pesar de
ello ellos eran más de 10.000 militares
entonces Haití está en esta duda de si
traer o no militares extranjeros después
de lo que pasó con la misión de paz cuál
cree usted que podría ser la solución
primero yo creo que la misión del 2004
de gasto muchísimo dinero en el país y
también que hizo todo lo que usted acaba
de enseñar al violación
de mujeres y muchísimas otras cosas Yo
creo que esta misión no tenía digamos
no tenía el objetivo de resolver de
verdad el problema haitiano Porque esa
misión el único rol positivo que que que
jugó era disuadir digamos en las fuerzas
de inseguridad en el país como las
bandas pero no estaba trabajando para
acompañarle verdad a la policía mientras
que uno de sus objetivos era acompañar
la policía fortalecer la policía esta
misión es este objetivo no no se alcanzó
sin embargo en el contexto actual la
única posibilidad para que Haití salga
de esta situación lo más rápido posible
es una intervención militar robusta sin
embargo la comunidad internacional
especialmente Estados Unidos y Canadá
que tienen la capacidad de
dirigir esta misión no tienen interés en
la situación actualmente en el país por
lo que yo no espero que venga esta
misión Sí y quiero quiero interrumpirlo
porque quiero interrumpirlo porque
quiero aprovechar el tiempo y hacerle la
última pregunta Y es que a Gael Rey
pospuso las elecciones que se tenían
previstas para noviembre de 2021 y la
última vez que hubo por la venta Arias
fue en 2015 se espera que en 2023 sí se
realicen los comicios qué tan necesario
son Y por qué no se han realizado
bueno
los comicios no se han realizado los
años pasados porque no hay no no hay las
condiciones mínimas para eso seguridad
administración electoral por eso y este
año se ha dicho que habrá elecciones
tampoco habrá elecciones
son de alguna forma Yo diría que son
necesarias porque habrá una digamos un
nuevo gobierno electo sin embargo lo que
necesitamos en Haití en realidad no son
elecciones es la emergencia de una nueva
clase política yo creo en el evento más
importante para mí actualmente no son
las elecciones son las sanciones
internacionales porque a sancionar
políticos haitianos corruptos yo creo
que ya no tengan la No tendrán la
capacidad de participar en elecciones Y
de alguna forma eso ayudará a la inercia
de una nueva clase política porque con
esos políticos que hay elecciones o no
no exactamente el mismo resultado
situación a la que estamos asistiendo
desde el 2011 por lo que lo que nos
importa lo que importa Haití y para
volver al problema la crisis estructural
no son elecciones sino la emergencia de
una nueva clase política